We face a very big choice.
What kind of country are we going to be?
What kind of country are we going to give our kids?
President Obama, he had his chance.
He made his choices.
His economic agenda: more spending, more borrowing, higher taxes, a government takeover of health care.
It's not working.
It's failed to create the jobs we need.
23 million Americans are struggling for work today.
15% of Americans are in poverty.
This is not what a real recovery looks like.
You deserve better.
Mitt Romney and I want to earn your support.
We're offering real reforms for a real recovery for every American.
Mitt Romney - his experience, his ideas, his solutions - is uniquely qualified to get this job done.
At a time when we have a jobs crisis in America, wouldn't it be nice to have a job creator in the White House?
The choice is clear:...
...a stagnant economy that promotes more government dependency or a dynamic, growing economy that promotes opportunity and jobs.
Mitt Romney and I will not duck the tough issues and we will not blame others for the next four years.
We will take responsibility.
And we will not try to replace our founding principles.
We will reapply our founding principles.
The choice is clear and the choice rests with you.
And we ask you for your vote.
Thank you.